the facts are disputed but the
consequences are clear a national of
Iran and Britain alireza akbari was
executed at the notorious Evan prison in
Tehran overnight
news of his death was broadcast to the
country on national TV
Mr ackberry was one of Britain's most
important spies says this presenter he
knowingly sold Secrets abroad a claim
that is vigorously disputed by his
family it is a political game it was a
political game he he was somebody that
was involved with the regime from the
very beginning of its foundation he was
holding senior positions somebody like
that was dedicated
to the country uh and to the regime
he was arrested in 2019 but details of
his detention and death sentence were
only revealed this week
Iranian television had the story however
broadcasting this obituary
we see akberry in this meeting
reconstructed for the cameras speaking
to a British agent wearing a blonde wig
finally the former official is seen
signing his confession papers although
he told family members on the phone it
was forced by means of torture the
Judiciary System in Iran is in no shape
or form credible particularly to the
outside world so it's difficult to
really assess
um how much of it is true how much of it
was indeed forced confessions and of
course we have to assume that when he
says he was put under under drugs or he
was tortured to to confess to things
that there is something to it this is
the first time in decades that a senior
Iranian official has been hanged akberry
charged and executed for corruption on
earth a catch-all for crimes like
treason
for others have been executed after
their involvement in anti-government
protests this time for a Waging War
against God and some think the two are
related act Barry's death a means to
deflect attention yeah the regime does
anything
that he can unfortunately to suppress
the population but also to the distract
the global
perspective on what is actually
happening to to to the to the people in
the country
according to the British government the
regime is responsible for heinous human
rights violations and it has responded
by temporarily withdrawing the
Ambassador we take this incredibly
seriously and of course we will make
sure that we respond to deter any
further actions like this being taken by
the Iranian government yet The clerics
Who Run Iran will not give way
voluntarily as they deal with their
purported enemies at home and abroad
John Sparks Sky News